Film Courage: I asked you this before but
when did you get “good” at acting.
When did you think you weren’t really mastering
the craft but honing in and what we talked
about earlier with the Bill Duke falling back
into the abyss.
Rhomeyn Johnson, Actor: Well like I said before
you never master, you get good or whatever.
There’s always something to learn.
And I always take classes and stay in classes
because of the fact that this is a work-in-progress.
But I think when I felt that I was really
connecting…I don’t like to say I really
got good.
I like to say when I really starting connecting
to what I was doing I think that was finally
when I stopped trying to be perfect see and
it kind of hurt me (that whole thing of perfection),
hurt me musically.
It didn’t hurt me as much as an actor and
it hasn’t hurt me as much as an actor but
it really hurt me musically because I got
into a thing (as far as singing and musical
stuff) trying to be too perfect.
Trying to make each note sound….laaaaa!
[Sings]…whatever.
And that gets you in your head and once you
get into your head with anything (especially
this) you are in trouble.
It’s like what Bill Duke was saying about
stage fright, that’s that ego and everything
when you are out here when you are out judging
yourself in what you are doing.
See that’s the same thing as getting in
your head “That didn’t sound good.”
Or “That note could sound better.”
Why are you performing?
That’s not good.
When you drop that perfection mindset and
accept the fact that you are not perfect then
you free yourself to the point now where you
can be the actor or be the character whatever,
you free yourself.
Then you are able to able to really let go
and have fun and explore, you free yourself.
Once you free yourself in anything, that’s
when you get good or great or whatever.
The best actors like he was saying [Bill Duke],
the best actors are the ones who free themselves
to just be like Meryl Streep, Phillip Seymour
Hoffman, Daniel Day Lewis.
I mean he is so into that he IS that person
that’s freedom.
Even though he is so in and locked in he is
still free.
He is free of Daniel Day Lewis who is a very
nice guy and what not normally.
I mean Daniel Day Lewis wouldn’t take a
bowling ball and throw it at someone trying
to hurt them.
Not Daniel Day Lewis but that character or
the person he is being would but he tried
to do that.
So that’s when to me when you try to do
that and that is when you finally recognize
and accept yourself for who you are and the
fact that you are not perfect.
Because most actors who try to do everything
perfect and …that’s bad because then you
are acting.
And somebody said (I don’t know who it was)
said “Whatever you do, don’t ever let
them see you act.”
Don’t ever let them see that because then
you are in trouble because then people are
looking at you like “Ahhhh?”
You’ve seen people perform or act and you
were like “Okay…that was okay.
I didn’t buy it.”
But the person who like you said Christian
Bale in VICE he was all the way in.
He wasn’t trying to be perfect.
He was so busy trying to be a flawed person…Dick
Cheney was a flawed person.
Christian Bale didn’t have to try and be
perfect.
If we get religious or something, the only
person who was closest to being perfect was
what?
Jesus?
Jesus Christ or somebody?
You know what I’m saying.
And Jesus Christ if you read The Bible and
any of that wasn’t perfect.
He had flaws too.
Once you get to the point of accepting yourself
and saying “Okay this is who I am, I’m
going to just get into this as me and I’m
just going to just let us go and be free and
just let go.
That’s when you’ve got some beautiful
stuff going on.
Film Courage: It was great too in VICE because
Dick was this restrained, there was sort of
this anger bubbling at the surface whereas
the character of his wife (played by Amy Adams
who was great) was emotional and power-driven
and it was a great combination to see the
two of them together and I left that film
thinking it was going to be this sexy, rock
n’ roll version of it and it took me an
hour to feel normal (whatever normal is) but
it was pretty emotional.
It really affected me.
Rhomeyn: Being an actor being like how Bill
Duke says it’s like falling into darkness
backwards to do that it’s like that whole
experiment if you’ve ever been in one of
those psychiatric…where you trust things
you know [trust fall] where somebody has to
catch you, you’ve got to let yourself…and
to be honest with you it’s hard to let yourself
go when somebody has got to catch you.
I mean I don’t care how great of an actor
you are, it’s hard to fall back and you’ve
got somebody trying to catch you that you
don’t know where you don’t know if they
are going to be able to catch your big fat
a$$ (like me).
It’s like me I’m still…I can’t because
I’m scared I’m going to hit my damn head.
But what he said was once you’re able to
basically free fall backwards then you are
there.
So there’s a little more work I need to
do.